but for those outside of existing
research in this domain it might be
difficult to know what Innovation looks
like and how scientific insights can be
turned into real practical solutions
that customers will use and pay for
that's why we are launching this with a
program that will bring together experts
in microbiome science technology and
Venture funding to offer an inside look
at areas where Solutions are really
urgently needed they will highlight
specific research questions customer
needs available data sets and discuss
strategies for modernization
as a result participants can select an
area of microbiome research that is most
ripe for new Solutions and insights and
offer their take on Innovative
approaches at the intersection of
business technology and biology
so the goal of the hackathon is to bring
together diverse teams that offer
business
computational and biotechnology insights
to innovate and solve real world
challenges connecting with a network of
experts and researchers in this domain
participation will be virtual enabling
anyone from around the world to join we
will offer easy to use solutions that
can be leveraged to analyze data on the
cloud identify translational insights
and quickly prototype a product as a
result qualified teams will be able to
present their minimal viable product or
MVP and demonstrate how it can be used
by potential customers
expert judges will review each prototype
offer suggestions and further mentorship
to the best teams
the hackathon will have a specific focus
on pre-clinical applications of ongoing
microbiome research that leverages
bioinformatics as a way to develop
consumer-focused solutions for real
customers
several Trends make this an especially
interesting Focus for the hackathon one
there is a growing availability of
interesting data sets that describe each
one of the focus areas gut skin and
vaginal microbiome Technologies for data
generation and Analysis are becoming
more affordable and much easier to use
and finally growing public awareness
about the microbiome lead to Growing
business opportunities with little
regulation let's talk a little more
about each one of these domains
the gut microbiome is one of the most
studies areas with a special interest in
gut sensitivity predisposition to weight
abnormalities and pre-diabetic
conditions that can all be addressed
without major clinical interventions
this opportunity leads to intense
competition and aggressive campaigns by
companies like biome Flora Thorne health
and Atlas biomen that are all working to
convince us that their test of the
microbiome has the potential for
practical guidance when it comes to our
gut health and obesity
these businesses capture the promise of
an extensive list of small-scale
clinical trials and base their research
on privately and publicly available data
for example biom advertises its test to
prescribe pre and probiotics other
companies recommend genetic testing and
activity tracking While others can
advise to measure even metabolites and
recommend intermittent fasting most
researchers agree that this field is
increasingly promising but more work
remains to be done to find specific
explanations and validation of found
associations your business analysis
ideas based on available data and
Technical Solutions can help which
approach is optimal what are the
customer needs which recommendations
bring the most value these questions
remain and finding answers requires a
deep understanding of the market
consumer sentiment Technologies and user
experiences that can all translate the
promise of microbiome testing an
application to get health obesity and
Wellness but gut health is not the only
area where the microbiome is being
touted as the ultimate solution women
and increasingly men are well aware of
their skin and looks skin dryness acne
and pigmentation can be major concerns
leading to tremendous efforts and
anxiety maybe that is why it's not
surprising that bacterial communities
that frequent our skin can hold answers
and solutions to address some of these
challenges
companies already offer microbiome
testing matching and treatment that
promises to revolutionize skin care
maybe you haven't thought of this yet
but now that you will see that the data
sets are available maybe your team can
find an Innovative solution and offer us
an Insight on how the solution can be
monetized
another intriguing area of research and
Innovation is related to something that
every single one of us went through in
one way or another childbirth
increasingly studies show that
conception pregnancy and childbirth are
associated with specific microbiota we
might not have discovered yet exactly
how but there's growing evidence that a
variety of factors are at play that can
have long-term consequences not only
before birth but also on the child
immunity and even psychology long after
increasingly companies are realizing how
a significant Market is emerging for
what is called femtech where microbiome
science and Discovery can be a major
source of innovation you too can
participate in the search for specific
signatures that can be useful for
pregnant women innovating in this five
billion dollar market
microbiome and health and wellness is a
hackathon that will take place in
November this year that will offer
students of all backgrounds an
opportunity to work together but before
we jump into the hackathon itself we
will start with a learning opportunity
that anyone can participate in
this learning we will address four major
issues that you have to understand
before trying to innovate
that includes sequencing Technologies
there are Trends in terms of depth
length of reads and cost of sequencing
data repositories which are available
for all of these different domains that
we just discussed
analysis of business trends that shows
strategies new consumer groups
and marketing opportunities
as well as an insight into user
experiences that can make this complex
science easy to understand for anyone
one major area that drives Innovation
and consumer-based Analysis of
microbiome are new sequencing
technologies that are increasingly easy
to use
and much more affordable
today using these Technologies
researchers can study the human
microbiome directly in its natural
environment and as these Technologies
are continuing to evolve they offer new
insights at lower costs so before we
jump into what these Solutions look like
we will hear some experts discuss what
are the latest trends and opportunities
that you can leverage as you think about
innovation
in addition to microbiome other types of
data could be useful as you consider the
specific types of applications that we
discussed most of these data types are
generated randomly and at high speed
requiring complex computational data
processing a procedure to generate a
structured data set which can be
visualized and analyzed statistically we
will focus on some of the ways that you
can leverage bioinformatics to analyze
and extract meaningful insights from
these data during the training sessions
we'll review some of the most common
analysis approaches to data processing
analysis and integration relying on some
of the commonly used reference databases
of microbiome taxonomy we will also
learn about other factors that can be
measured both with molecular and
non-molecular measurements to offer
insights that can be used by consumers
and that can give you some ideas about
how innovative solutions can be proposed
in addition we will learn about some of
the latest trends dominant Market
players as well as Market segmentation
in this domain and think about what
separates clinical and pre-clinical
research in the microbiome field what
opportunities are most interesting to
investors and how specific market
segments can be captured through
innovative solutions that your team
might propose
to address these topics we have invited
distinguished scientists investors that
are active in the space as well as
companies that are already innovating
offering solutions to other companies as
well as direct to Consumers we're
excited to make this hackathon in
training available to our academic
partners and students in their Network
student teams from anywhere in the world
can start registering October 1st 2022
if you are from a partner University you
will benefit from steep discounts which
can be obtained by registering with your
official University email ID
if your university has still not joined
our partnership program we invite you to
recommend it to your faculty and
administration to speak to our team
about participating we already have an
extensive partner Network that
represents over 50 000 users and we
bring together over 10 University
Partners in the US India Brazil Nigeria
and Israel in fact the partner program
is designed to introduce data skills
across all life science domains where
the amount of data being generated every
day exceeds the volume of Twitter or
even astronomy data and that's why we
created omics logic a virtual community
of biology and biotechnology and
biomedical research students learning
data science we offer training
mentorship and user-friendly data
analysis tools to work with real-world
data problems omic's logic is free to
start and assumes no background
engineering computer science or
mathematics anyone from high school to
postgraduate level can start build out
their skills and develop project ideas
from a network of top research Labs
offering a curated library of case
studies as students complete their
profiles and develop a project portfolio
companies can find unique skills at
affordable rates finding their work and
tracking their skill mastery in addition
our team offers an extensive Mentor
community that is composed of
accomplished researchers and talented
students from around the world we host
regular seminars from experts and
researchers that provide unique insights
into the latest trends and challenges in
this Dynamic and complex field of
bioinformatics to become a part of our
community start by registering on our
portal and go to
learn.omexlogic.com to explore some of
the resources that we offer we're
excited to see your participation in
this hackathon on microbiome in health
and wellness go to the website at the
bottom of the slide and join